[موسيقى]
امن الغذائي في اربع مكونات سميتها باللغه
الانجليزيه الفور ايزي اللي هي
او نبدا
اللي هي الوفره وفره الغذاء الاكسس او
الاكسس امكانيه الوصول للغذاء لان الغذاء
ممكن يكون متوفر متوفره بس موجود بمخازن
ما في امكانيه الوصول يجب ان يكون الوصول
موجود لي بعد كده يجي الافورد اللي هو
التحكم في الاسعار وخصوصا دعم السلع
الرئيسيه وتمكين اصحاب الدخل المحدود من
قدره الشراء على الغذاء واخيرا ياتي او
مناسبه الغذاء للصحه العامه اللي هو نتكلم
على صحه الغذاء او الغذاء الصحي المكون
لانه احيانا يكون الغذاء متوفر بس هو غير
صحي
الفور ايز هذه تواجهها في المقابل اربع
تحديات رئيسيه سميت او ما اطلقت عليها
الفورسيز
وهي التحديات الاساسيه للامن الغذائي
اولها وخصوصا
ونتكلم على النزاعات طويله العمل
ونجد منها في منطقتنا الكثير بدايه من
فلسطين الى اليمن وسوريا وغيرها من الدول
التي تمر بزعزعه في الامن القومي ثانيا
والتغير المناخي تغير المناخي يتسبب اولا
فيما يعرف او التغيرات المناخيه للجو
بالتالي مواسم هطول الامطار تتاخر ومواسم
الحصاد والزراعه وكلها تتاثر بمواسم هطول
الامطار ياتي بعدها في التحديات الثالثه
وهي
الكلام هي الازمات وشاهدنا منها مؤخرا
ازمه كوفيد 19 جائحه تبعتها كذلك ازمه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في منطقه البحر
الاسود وخصوصا هذه الحرب لانها هذه منطقه
توفر حوالي 30% من حاجه العالم من الحبوب
وس من حاجه العالم العربي تقصد خصوصا
واكثر من 80% من حاجه العالم من الزيوت
السيل الاخيره هي ما يعرف بالكلب او
الكونسيومر وهو المستهلك ونتكلم هنا على
انماط الاستهلاك وعادات الاستهلاك احنا
اليوم مع حاجتنا للغداء ولدينا 800 مليون
مواطن وشخص على مستوى العالم مهددين
بالجوع احنا نتكلم على 800 مليون في اخر
اليوم قد يذهبون الى النوم بدون اكل في
اخر اليوم 800 مليون شخص على مستوى العالم
ومع ذلك مستوى الفاقد والهادر في الغذاء
لازال يصل الى 30 واربعين وفي بعض معدلات
في بعض الدول اكثر من 45% من الغذاء
المنتج بعد الاستهلاك يرمى في شكل فضلات
اول هذه المجالات هو التكنولوجيا
الاستثمار في التقنيه لانه الاستمرار في
انتاج الغذاء بالاوضاع الحاليه وباليات
الري القديمه لا يمكن ان يكون مستداما
هناك استهلاك كبير للمياه الري بالغمر
اصبح غير صالح وحتى الريب الرش العادي
يسمع غير صالح وبالتالي يجب ان ننظر الى
بدائل الري بالحقن والري بالتنقيط لتقليل
استهلاك المياه التي
تقلل من استهلاك المياه الى نسب تصل الى
60 وسبعين بالمئه تاني اتي هو تريد او
التجاره وهنا نتكلم على التجاره في
الطرفين سواء كانت التجاره في استيراد سلع
غذائيه اساسيه او الاستثمار خارجا
لاستزراع اراضي لدى دول اخرى لديها
امكانيات الارض والمياه لصالح هذه الدوله
مع ضمان ان هناك اخلاقيات عامه يبقى عليها
حتى نضمن ان لا يسبب كارثه في مكان اخر
ياتي بعد ذلك ما يعرف بالتريتوري او
الاقليميه داخل الدوله وهنا نتكلم على
زياده
الانتاجيه الداخليه
فزياده داخل الانتاجيه الداخليه لانه هناك
العديد من الدول في السنوات الاخيره ارتات
الاعتماد على الاستيراد بشكل كامل وايقاف
تقريبا الانتاجيه المحليه لبعض السلع تاتي
بعد ذلك الترند اللي هي تتكلم على سلوكيات
استهلاك الغذاء فبالتالي احد المعالجات
يجب ان نقلل في الهادر والفقر في الغذاء
يجب ان نركز على الغذاء الصحي
وندعم بشكل توعوي وبشكل تعليمي وربما حتى
بشكل تقنيني من خلال سن بعض القانون
والتشريعات للتقليل من الهيدرو والفاقد في
الغذاء وتحسين اليات استهلاك الغذاء